according to democrats january 6th was
the turning point for democracy and one
of the most important dates in american
history and that's why you have to give
them total power i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
[Music]
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
standup for your digital rights take
action at expressvpn.com
ben we'll get to all the news in just
one moment first you already know
inflation is now at 40-year highs the
federal reserve is considering
increasing interest rates because they
have to taper otherwise the inflation
will run out of control maybe you don't
want to rely on the federal reserve for
all of your asset base to be maintained
this might be why you would diversify
into precious metals the way that i have
think about this right now inflation
rates are higher than the interest on
treasury bonds so that every day that
passes the government owes less on its
mountain of debt imagine if your
mortgage payment had a negative interest
rate would you be in a hurry to pay it
off you would not so your pain is their
gain protect your savings now hedge
against inflation with gold from birch
gold because the government is indeed
sabotaging the value of the united
states dollar birch gold will help you
convert an eligible ira or 401k into an
ira backed by real gold that is peace of
mind and that is why i am a birch gold
customer with thousands of satisfied
customers and an a plus rating with the
better business bureau you can trust
birch gold to protect your savings text
ben to 989898 to get a free information
kit on gold and when you buy before the
end of the month birch gold will send
you a copy of my newest book the
authoritarian moment text been to 98 98
get your free information kit today
again text ben 298 9898 get your free
information kit today okay so today is
january 6th it is the first anniversary
of the only important moment in modern
american history according to the left
here is the thing the reason that the
left is paying attention to january 6th
is pure politics this is pure political
theater because politics is always
politics and it is not possible to be
too cynical about politics it really is
not the big news of the day is not
january 6. the big news of the day is
that the federal reserve officials at
their meeting last month according to
the wall street journal are now eyeing a
faster timetable for raising interest
rates this year potentially as soon as
march and democrats are panicking
because when the fed raises the interest
rates yes inflation gets curbed but also
unemployment is likely to go up because
typically when you raise the interest
rates you make it harder for people to
borrow when you make it harder for
people to borrow they cannot then spend
that money on hiring people and so
employment tends to go down and so
democrats are freaking the they're
freaking the hell out and they should be
freaking out
this is all bad policy brought about by
joe biden's interventionist take on
on economics
and the federal reserve raising its
rates is going to have some pretty dire
effects for the democrats come 2022 in
the midterm elections according to the
wall street journal minutes of their
december 14th to 15th meeting released
wednesday showed officials believe that
rising inflation in a very tight labor
market could call for lifting short-term
rates sooner or a faster pace than
participants had earlier anticipated
some officials also thought the fed
should start shrinking its 8.76 trillion
dollar portfolio of bonds and other
assets relatively soon after beginning
to raise the rates investors would see
the moves another way for the fed to
tighten financial conditions to cool the
economy
and the predictable effect of this
revelation is that stocks immediately
dumped
they turned sharply lower after the
minutes were released on wednesday
afternoon the the dow jones fell 1.1
percent the nasdaq lost 3.3
meanwhile government bond yields rose on
wednesday
trading in interest rate futures implied
a roughly two-thirds probability that
the fed would raise rates in march okay
so what does this mean it means that
democrats desperately desperately have
to redirect to january 6. so both kamala
harris the vice president of the united
states and joe biden spoke at the
capitol rotunda this morning they did so
because of course they have to make hay
while the sun shines january 6th being
the most important thing in history joe
biden is not great at this commonwealth
is just absolutely abysmal at this so
joe biden was able to sort of cover some
of his some of his tracks kamala harris
just kind of puts it all right out there
here in this very building
a decision will be made
about whether we uphold the right to
vote
and ensure free and fair elections
let's be clear
we must pass
voting rights bills that are now before
the senate
and
the american people
must also do something more
we cannot
sit on the sidelines
we must unite
in defense
of our democracy
here was vice president kamala harris
claiming that january 6th was just like
wait for it pearl harbor and 9 11.
certain dates echo throughout history
including dates that instantly
remind all who have lived through them
where they were
and what they were doing
when our democracy came under assault
dates that occupy
not only a place on our calendars
but a place
in our collective memory
december 7th 1941
september 11
and january 6
2021.
uh here's joe biden talking about the
threat to democracy from which he must
save us all
i did not seek this fight
brought to this capital one year ago
today
but i will not shrink from it either
i will stand in this breach
i will defend this nation
not allow no one to place a dagger at
the throat of democracy
we will make sure the will of the people
is heard
that the ballot prevails not violence
but authority in this nation will always
be peacefully transferred i mean this is
joe biden's entire stick his entire
shtick is democracy was under grave
unbelievable unprecedented threat on
january 6th but he will stand in the
breach all you have to do is give him
complete ultimate power
you can't love your country only when
you win
you can't obey the law only when it's
convenient
can't be patriotic when you embrace and
enable lies
those who stormed this capital
and those who instigated and incited
and those who called on them to do so
held a dagger at the throat of america
an american democracy it's so tiresome
and so tiresome because we know the game
that he's playing right i mean the game
that he is playing right here is let me
pass the legislation i want otherwise
you are the dagger at the throat of
democracy when he compares what happened
on january 6th to the edmund pettus
bridge you know like black people being
beaten up for being black as part of a
broader jim crow effort to subvert the
rights of black people when he compares
it to
when he compares it to december 7th what
he's really saying is that anybody who
disagrees with his agenda is the enemy
because when he says he wants a
renaissance of democracy he does not
mean respect for elections purely and
simply
what he really means is pass my voting
rights act he means let me add 87
justices to the supreme court and kill
the filibuster and federalize election
procedure that's what he means it's a
political game and pretending that it's
not pretending that this is all just
good-hearted let's get together and be
more civil about our election that's not
what he's doing and anyone with half a
brain knows that's not what he's doing
okay the worse things get for the
democrats the more they're going to
redirect to january 6th now why
i mean this is the real question that
should be asked why so january 6th was a
bad moment in american history it was
and it was a moment in american history
what i mean by that is that president
trump spent from november 4th to january
6th telling people that he had duly won
the election and that for fraudulent
reasons joe biden was being selected as
president
and then he had his legal advisors
telling people falsely that under the
electoral contact the vice president of
the united states had the capacity to
simply throw away state-certified votes
that is not true donald trump had every
legal avenue available to him to
challenge election results he did it
sometimes he didn't allege half of the
stuff that he has alleged publicly and
so by the time that it came time to
certify the election which happened in
early december by the time that happened
the trump team had basically
made no case as to why states should
throw out their own election results
that is not to deny that there is
election fraud in a country with 155
million votes there will be some
election fraud this is not to deny that
there wasn't screwing around with the
elections given the procedures of 2020.
thanks to the pandemic and thanks to
democratic opportunism there are a bunch
of absentee ballots that were being sent
out to people who did not ask for them
or you had
increased
drop in mailboxes or you had increase in
terms of the the number of people who
were voting early right all of this is
true
and it is also true that the election
was in fact rigged from the perspective
of the media silencing information
preventing true information from getting
to the public and manipulating
information that you did see right all
of that can be true and also donald
trump did not have a legal case for
overturning the election and there's
just the simple fact of the matter if he
had a legal case for overturning the
election he would have won some cases
legally he did not win and he won one
case legally and that was quickly
overturned out of something like 80
across the country
okay and the ballot recounts that have
been done in places like georgia and in
arizona including the audit that was
done in arizona the much ballyhooed
maricopa county audit found that there
was not mass electoral fraud on the
scale necessary to declare that donald
trump had won the election in arizona
for example
okay so donald trump from november 4th
to january 6 was maintaining that he was
the rightfully elected president of the
united states or that the election was
totally fraudulent or that the senate
majority leader and the vice president
of the united states had the legal
capacity to simply throw out duly
certified state votes that was not true
but donald trump did not tell people to
storm the capitol building he did not he
said that people should peacefully
protest at the capitol building so a
bunch of people went over there there
was a huge rally i mean like tens of
tens of thousands of people
the vast majority of those people went
home the vast majority of those people
did not engage in the violence of the
capitol building and then several
hundred people did engage in violence at
the capitol building something like 100
police officers were injured and some of
those people broke into the capitol
building and some of the people in the
capitol building were running around
yelling for mike pence
or assaulting police officers and some
of those people were just kind of
wandering around inside okay that is
what happened on january 6th and then
within three hours the entire place was
clear all the congress people were back
in their seats and mitch mcconnell and
mike pence were certifying the election
that's what actually happened on january
6th
okay we were all there we all remember
it it was bad it was not good
the president of the united states
waited too long to tell people to go
home but
all of that said was this a full-blown
coup no because a coup requires some
sort of institutional support that would
legitimate
a a failure of an effective transition
of power and people say there was no
peaceful transition of power that is a
lie there was a peaceful transition of
power the presence of a riot does not
mean that there was no peaceful
transition of power if that were the
case there was no peaceful transition of
power back in 2017 when donald trump at
his inauguration there were massive
riots outside trump's inauguration
involving the arrest over 200 people was
that a peaceful transition of power it
was because joe biden left and donald
trump took office well on january 20th
of 2021 donald trump left and joe biden
took office that is called a peaceful
transition of power was this a moment of
crisis for our democracy no it wasn't
within three hours of
idiots invading the capitol building the
election was being certified
so then why is this a moment of national
disgrace a moment of national shame and
the answer is because for the left it
must be it must be because the left's
goal within 24 hours of this event
forget 24 hours and 24 minutes of this
event it became wildly apparent that for
the democrats and for the media this was
gold and it was gold because they got to
try and lump in everyone who voted with
trump two people who protested the
election and then lumping all those
people with the capital rioters so the
idea was that if you voted for trump or
if you voted against biden or if you
would ever consider voting for trump or
if you would ever consider voting for
any other republican you were complicit
in the actions of january 6th this
became perfectly clear when parlor was
knocked offline by amazon web services
amazon web services is a neutral service
provider the suggestion was that parlor
had been used to organize the january
6th riots and therefore parlor needed to
be dumped offline well facebook was used
much more than parlor for that they
weren't dumped offline twitter was used
twitter was not dumped offline became
very clear very quickly that major
institutions in the united states were
going to use january 6th
as the excuse and the predicate for
cracking down on political opposition
and that's what continues today
the left's argument is that january 6th
is not just something that happened it's
not just a bad thing perpetrated by
people who acted criminally and are
going to jail it was not even about
donald trump saying things that were not
true it was not about any of that it was
about a full-fledged attempt by the
right wing in the united states to
subvert democracy and that can only be
stopped according to the left by
allowing them to subvert democracy
tear away at the fundamental
institutions of republicanism in this
country get rid of the senate filibuster
for example so they can pass a voting
rights act which is not really a voting
rights act it's a federalization of
elections act
complete with insanely loose election
restrictions
right this is their argument their
argument is you must give them total
power to prevent the republicans from
taking total power because after all
those evil evil republicans are seeking
to take total power
now what are they basing that on they're
basing that on the fact that there are
laws that have been passed in states
like georgia that shore up certain
election procedures and actually loosen
certain election procedures everyone who
looks at the georgia law just facially
understands this is not a a device for
stealing elections in georgia anyone who
suggests to you that the georgia
election law is about republican
stealing election is out of their mind
or lying to you
the the great election threat here does
not exist okay republicans are not
stealing elections across the country
the the left is suggesting for example
that the john lewis voting rights act be
used in order to crack down on
particularly red states when it comes to
redistricting there's only one problem
according to cook political in
republican states in which they've
engaged in redistricting this year
there really is no major shift toward
republican seats there's actually more
of a shift in democratic states with
democratic redistricting than there is
in republican states with republican
redistricting in other words this is not
a major problem
but democrats have decided it's a major
problem because they wish to use this as
the excuse to seize more power
that's what this is about this is not a
sincere effort nobody believes this is
sincerely about january 6th
if it were like which part of it would
be sincere from the left the part where
they're very upset about people
protesting elections
who's going to make that case governor
stacey abrams of georgia lost an
election by 50 000 votes and was
declared in 2020 a governor of georgia
by the democratic party at their
national convention
who exactly on the democratic side of
the aisle is really upset about people
who protest elections the same people
who spent four years declaring that
donald trump was only president because
of russian collusion and facebook memes
or maybe we're supposed to believe that
the democratic left is deeply deeply
upset and angry over the treatment of
police officers on january 6th i mean
hell the new york times has an entire
piece today titled capital police bear
scars of riots
okay now i just have a question
about 100 police officers 120 police
officers were injured on january 6th
over the course of the black lives
matter riots which were predicated on a
huge lie
a much bigger lie by the way in
consequence for literally millions of
americans than the lie that president
trump openly won the 2020 election for
example the lie that america's police
are systemically racist targeting black
men and shooting them down in the
streets that's what black lives matter
was predicated upon it was a full-blown
lie promoted by every major democrat to
the point where you had the current vice
president of the united states bailing
rioters out of jail
in minnesota
in those riots over 2 000 police
officers were injured not one word from
democrats on this so are we supposed to
believe that the reason that they're
truly that this is a truly historic
event is because of mistreatment of
police is that what we're meant to
believe from the media and the democrats
which part of january 6th is is the part
that they are are really they're
standing on solid ground in terms of
their own approach toward for example
elections or treatment of police or
treatment of political violence which
they went and nodded at in some cases
openly promoted in the middle of 2020
that's why as always this is a political
game and pretending that it is anything
but a political game is being pretty
damned dishonest
we'll get some more of this in just one
second
first let's talk about a simple fact you
require
life insurance you do i mean let's say
that you are just walking down the
street and it's in florida and so
suddenly an alligator is just leaping at
you well as that alligator leaps at you
and as you fend it off and as it begins
to sink its teeth into your jugular vein
you might be thinking man i should have
listened to shapiro and gone and gotten
some life insurance head on over to
policygenius.com shapiro answer a few
questions about yourself in minutes you
can work out how much life insurance
coverage you need compare personalized
quotes to find your best price it could
save 50 or more on life insurance by
comparing quotes with policy genius
their licensed experts will help you
understand your options and apply for a
policy the policy genius team works for
you not the insurance companies you can
trust them to offer unbiased help and
advocate for you at every step until you
are covered policy genius does not add
on extra fees policy genius doesn't sell
your information to third parties policy
genius has thousands of five-star
reviews across google and trust pilots
so what exactly are you waiting for
they've already helped 30 million people
shop for insurance they placed 120
billion dollars in coverage they can
certainly help you head on over to
policygenius.com
shapiro get your free life insurance
quotes see how much you could save
that's policygenius.com
shapiro so joe biden says are we going
to be a nation that accepts political
violence as a norm i don't know joe are
we
where were you for all of summer 2020
where where was your entire party for
all of summer 2020 when i was locked in
my home in l.a thanks to the riots that
were occurring on sunset boulevard and
down the street from beyond what's it i
just have a question where were you
are we gonna be a nation that accepts
political violence as a norm you already
did
you already did don't shed me no
crocodile tears about january 6th after
you spend an entire summer green
lighting five billion dollars in
uninsured property damage across the
country and pretending it's not a big
deal because after all george floyd
biden says are we gonna be a nation
where we allow partisan election
officials to overturn the legally
express will
of the people well i mean i don't know
joe are we nancy pelosi challenged a
duly held election in the state of iowa
in which there is a very close
congressional race and she up she held
up the results for months
there's even talk of seating the
democrat in place of the republican in
that particular race so i'm all for
verifiable procedures i'm all for
certified elections being carried
forward i think that mike pence and
mitch mcconnell did the right thing on
january of 2020.
i also think
that it would be good if if states for
example
carry out their votes and then tally
their votes and then certify their votes
without political interference
i agree with that i'm just wondering
do you still think that governor stacey
abrams is the governor of georgia
says we can't allow ourselves to be that
kind of nation joe biden is going to
speak about january 6th incessantly
because he's a crappy president and he
has to get you to think about something
else don't pay attention to the
inflation over here please don't pay
attention to the fact that we are
shutting down schools in chicago and in
new york and in philadelphia or at least
trying in new york don't don't pay
attention to any of that pay attention
to the fact that that january 6th
happened see the shiny object pay
attention to this hand not to this hand
so jen sachi talked a little bit
yesterday about biden's plans for
january 6th here's what she had to say
president biden has been uh clear-eyed
about the threat the former president
represents to our democracy and how how
the former president constantly works to
undermine basic american values and rule
of law and president biden has of course
spoken repeatedly about how the former
president abused his office undermined
the constitution and ignored his oath to
the american people in an effort to
amass more power for himself and his
allies uh he sees january 6 as the
tragic culmination of what those four
years under president trump did to our
country
okay that right there is the key right
so for when gen zaki says that joe biden
sees january 6th this is a tragic
culmination of what trump did to the
country okay first of all the democratic
idea about politics is that the world
began spinning the moment trump became
president and then it stopped spinning
on january 6th that is the only period
of history that we are ever allowed to
look at actually there are a couple
periods right there's when america
allowed slavery and then you fast
forward all the way to trump becoming
president
and the the these are these are the only
periods in american history that have
ever mattered according to the left
apparently
so when gen zaki says that what she
means to do is to tie every trump policy
to january 6th if you supported trump's
tax cuts well it did culminate in
january 6. if you supported trump's
foreign policy the abraham accords
strengthening our position via china
vis-a-vis china well that did culminate
in january 6th if you supported trump's
judicial nominees well that did
culminate in january 6th
right she's not being specific
deliberately she's being deliberately
vague because the idea is if you
disagree with us on any of these things
you are part of the problem
you're part of the problem
okay so they have to continue to
maintain that there is this vast threat
to american democracy that justifies
exactly what they are doing
and again what's amazing about this is
they are not hiding the ball in any way
shape or form
if you mention it people get mad at you
because we're all supposed to believe
that the only thing that matters in
american life is january 6th
but they are pretty much just saying it
they are pretty much just saying what it
is that they want to do
[Music]
they want to push this rejiggering of
all voting law that is the goal
and they're going to use this as the
lever to do it
and this is not a shock this is what
people do in politics it's not unique to
democrats not unique to republicans
politicians exploit situations january
6th is a situation democrats believe
they can exploit and so they will shed
crocodile tears in orders that they can
push forward a bunch of stuff they
wanted to do anyway
that is the goal here
and that is why you're seeing them play
up the notion that there's like this
giant threat okay january 6th is not
going to be repeated today
that's not a thing
i mean they spent months putting barbed
wire around the capitol when there was
no threat
none
why because they had to maintain the
idea that there is a threat so great
that you have to let us do exactly what
we want to do
we'll get some more of this in just one
second because this is the universal
message from the left on january 6th the
first anniversary first did you know
that one out of three americans
regularly suffer from nausea we've all
experienced that horrible feeling it is
no fun my wife tends to get very very
carsick for example well instead of
suffering with nausea instead get
something called relief band relief band
is great so my wife uses relief band
when we're on long car drives and she
tends to get that sort of car sickness
my sister also she tends to get carsick
as well and she had some morning
sickness because she's pregnant we got a
relief down as well it is very very
useful relief and is the number one fda
cleared anti-nausea wristband and has
been clinically proven so quickly
relieve and effectively prevent nausea
and vomiting associated with motion
sickness anxiety migraines hangovers
morning sickness chemo and so much more
the product is 100 drug-free non-drowsy
provides all-natural long-lasting relief
with zero side effects for as long as
needed the technology was originally
developed over 20 years ago in hospitals
to relieve nausea from patients now
through a relief band it's available to
the masses relief band stimulates the
nerve in the wrist it travels to the
part of the brain that controls nausea
then it blocks the signal your brain is
sending to your stomach telling you that
you're sick relief band just introduced
its newest model relief band sport the
sport is waterproof features
interchangeable bands and has extended
battery life as well don't let nausea
keep you from doing the things you love
right now relief band has an exclusive
offer just for ben shapiro listeners if
you go to reliefband.com and use promo
code shapiro you'll receive 20 off plus
free shipping no questions asked 30 day
money-back guarantee head on over to
r-e-l-i-e-f-b-a-n-d.com use our promo
code shapiro for 20 off plus free
shipping okay so
joe biden's entire stick here is again
to promote the idea that democracy is
under grave threat and therefore we can
do what we want he's trotting out his
dhs secretary alejandro mayorkas to say
there is indeed a continuing and real
threat from insurrectionists allah
january 6 meanwhile why don't we leave
the southern border open like completely
open we'll just we'll do that here's
alejandro mayorka's the the terrible
terrible head of homeland security
domestic violent extremism uh does in
fact remain one of the greatest threats
that we face on the homeland and what we
in the department of homeland security
do
uh is
obtain information and share information
and make sure that not only we across
the federal enterprise but also our
state and local partners
are fully equipped with the information
and best
positioned
to prevent a threat from materializing
the threat is real but it is our job to
be prepared for it and to be uh
responsive if in fact it should
materialize
okay no the threat of a coup is not real
the threat of a mass scale insurrection
is not real
i mean how how motivated are democrats
to come up
with this narrative they've been setting
polls showing that something like four
percent of americans want trump to lead
a coup right now
ten percent of americans think elvis is
still alive and the margin of error on
these polls is like four percent
but we're supposed to believe that
there's
10 million americans who are who are
desperate for and willing to pick up
arms in order to effectuate a coup uh no
no by the way the people who violated
the law on january 6th have been
prosecuted to the hilt by the federal
government
much much more than the rioters of black
lives matter summer
there are literally thousands of people
committing crimes across the country
during 2020.
a huge majority of those people are not
going to jail
i wish to god that we had the same sort
of law and order attitude toward the
rioters of 2020 that we did toward the
rioters of january 6th
this is why i don't believe democrats
when they start talking about yes so
well january 6th it's all about law
order here's merrick garland doing that
routine
with increasing numbers of individuals
having breached the capital
members of the senate and the house of
representatives
including the president of the senate
vice president mike pence
had to be evacuated
as a consequence proceedings in both
chambers were disrupted for hours
interfering with a fundamental element
of american democracy
the peaceful transfer of power
from one administration to the next
those involved must be held accountable
and there is no higher priority for us
at the department of justice
it's the only priority at the department
of justice because the department of
justice is a political tool of the biden
administration well how about honestly
like it's not what about us who say that
there is a standard and it should apply
across the board if it does not apply
across the board i have a feeling that
it's politically driven that's not what
about ism
it's not what it is because i think that
the people who broke the law on january
6 should go to jail it would be what
about ism if i were making the argument
that they shouldn't go to jail but if
you broke the law you should go to jail
but i believe that about everybody who
breaks the law
but merrick garland doj don't believe
that they're currently cramming down
consent decrees on police departments
making it easier for criminals to
effectuate their crime
here's here's merrick garland continuing
along these lines january 6th of course
being the only important event in
american history
the actions we have taken
thus far will not be our last
the justice department remains committed
to holding all january 6 perpetrators
at any level
accountable under law
whether they were present that day
or were otherwise criminally responsible
for the assault on our democracy
we will follow the facts
wherever they lead
okay meanwhile this is so i have some
doubts about the way that this sort of
stuff is is portrayed the reason i have
some doubts about the way this is
portrayed is because for example the
idea here is that trump led the
insurrection okay now again
trump said things that were not true
between november 4th and january 6th
i've been very clear about this
i do not think that trump had the
evidence to overturn the 2020 election i
don't think he presented it in court i
don't think that the allegations that he
made publicly are the ones he tried to
substantiate in court it's not that i
don't think that i know that because
i've looked at the court filings
okay but when when president trump is
accused of for example quote unquote
inciting the violence of the capital
okay there's two questions here one is
did he incite the violence at the
capitol and two is did he tamp it down
fast enough once it broke out two is
still an open question at the very least
one is not really an open question
because the fact is he said in his
speech to peacefully protest at the
capitol building i felt a very
consistent standard on this if a
politician raises the level of rhetoric
he is guilty for raising the level of
rhetoric he is not guilty of incitement
bernie sanders is not guilty for the
congressional baseball shooting barack
obama was not guilty for the 2016
assassination of six dallas police
officers and donald trump is not guilty
for the break-in at the capitol building
but the goal for the media is always to
turn whatever trump says into incitement
so for example
yesterday trump put out a statement
regarding vax mandates he said the biden
administration's response to covet is
getting worse every day joe biden said
there is no federal solution to the
pandemic but he then federalized the
distribution of antibodies red states
are getting the short end of the stick
in my administration we respected the
role of governors to take care of their
own states and they could request
antibodies and therapeutics depending on
what they needed that's the way our
country is supposed to run
now there's talk by the biden
administration again about closing
schools and even vast mandates for
school children this is an outrage
the federal government must be reined in
and give people back the freedom to
decide whether they want to be
vaccinated or not
right and he suggests that mega should
quote unquote rise up right he says that
the exact phrase that he uses is this is
an outrage and magnation should rise up
and oppose this egregious federal
government outreach
okay overreach
okay so the media immediately said that
because he used the language rise up he
means violent insurrection no he doesn't
no he doesn't people use that language
routinely when it comes to politics
i mean that's that's just
that's silly that's silly
but again the goal is any association
with january 6 can be used to smear
literally everyone
and and that is uh at the very least
wildly objectionable but that's the
talking point for today
and so we have jimmy carter writing
guest pieces for the new york times
about fearing for democracy we'll get to
that in just one second first
if you haven't taken advantage of record
low mortgage rates now would be the time
they're not going to be here much longer
the fed has told us a few times now
every day that passes you know what's
going to happen we are at risk of seeing
higher mortgage rates in the very near
future it will cost you money so please
find out what your options are you can
get a free mortgage review by calling
our friends at american financing where
you can learn about ways to save up to a
thousand bucks a month and tens of
thousands of bucks long term you can
even skip two mortgage payments and you
might be able to close in as fast as 10
days there's a lot of savings in your
back pocket ready for you to grab but
you've got to call now before these
rates get higher eight six six seven two
one thirty three hundred that's eight
six six seven two one thirty three
hundred now is the best time probably in
american history to refi your mortgage
because the rates are at historic lows
again they're not going to remain that
way for long we already know the federal
reserve is looking to taper
that means mortgage rates are likely to
rise as early as late this spring summer
that means you really should get on the
ball right now go to
americanfinancing.net give them a call
at 866-721-3300
that's 866 721 3300 and mls 182 334 nmls
consumer access dot org go check them
out right now okay so and the entire
media are now repeating the democratic
talking points because this is this is
what we do and so we have jimmy carter
the 1 000 year old former president of
the united states writing in the new
york times about how we almost
descended into complete tyranny in
january of 2020.
we didn't
i'm sorry we didn't there was no
institutional support for the capitol
riders who were cleared from the capitol
building i repeat again within three
hours they went to jail and then the
election was certified by donald trump's
vice president
but according to jimmy carter it was a
crisis for democracy and that crisis has
not abated
he says one year ago a violent mob
guided by unscrupulous politicians
stormed the capital and almost succeeded
in preventing the democratic transfer of
power no they didn't they didn't even
come close to preventing the democratic
transfer power
they did not come within a hundred yards
of
of preventing the democratic transfer of
power they occupied a building were
cleared from the building within three
hours
the only person who was killed by the
way is one of the protesters shot ashley
babbitt
everybody else who died died of a heart
attack or died of other extraneous
conditions there's no direct evidence
that any police officer was murdered on
january 6th
and uh and
but again it has to be blown up into we
were on the verge of losing our
democracy which of course is really
really really silly
he says all four of us former presidents
condemned their actions and affirmed the
legitimacy of the 2020 election that
followed a brief hope that the
insurrection would shock the nation into
addressing the toxic polarization that
threatens our democracy is what jimmy
carter captain polarization himself has
to say however
one year on promoters of the lie that
the election was stolen have taken over
one political party and stoked distrust
in our electoral systems these forces
exert power and influence the relentless
disinformation which continues to turn
americans against americans politicians
in my home state of georgia as well as
in others such as texas and florida have
leveraged the distrust they have created
to enact laws that empower partisan
legislatures to intervene in election
processes they seek to win by any means
and many americans are being persuaded
to think and act likewise threatening to
collapse the foundations of our society
and democracy with breathtaking speed i
now fear that what we have fought so
hard to achieve globally the right to
free fair elections unhindered by
strongman politicians has become
dangerously fragile at home okay so i i
have a question for jimmy carter
in 2006 jimmy carr i mean speaking of
free and fair elections jimmy carter
in 2006 presided over an election in the
gaza strip
okay in the middle east that election
was won by hamas hamas is a terrorist
group that election was marred by
tremendous abuses of power because hamas
is as stated a terrorist group
jimmy carter then proceeded to certify
that election and say that election was
good and say that hamas should be given
a chance so i'm just wondering what leg
he has to stand on in talking about
democracy promotion and electoral fraud
but you know they've got to call
everybody out of the woodwork to make
the case
he he makes some recommendations he says
first while citizens can disagree on
policies people of all political stripes
must agree on fundamental constitutional
principles and norms of fairness
civility and respect for the rule of law
agree i have no problem
with any of that
i'm just wondering why it only applies
to one side of the political aisle but i
have no problem with any of that second
we must push for reforms that ensure the
security and accessibility of our
elections and ensure public confidence
in the accuracy of results
okay that's again no objections third we
must resist the polarization that is
reshaping our identities around politics
we must focus on a few core truths that
we are all human we're all americans we
have common hopes for our communities
and our country to thrive again agree
fourth violence has no place in our
politics we must act urgently to pass or
strengthen laws to reverse the trends of
character assassination intimidation and
the presence of armed militias at events
um
okay i don't know how that is going to
materialize in a country where we still
respect the first amendment
right there is a pretty wide distinction
between violence in politics and
trends of character assassination
that's that seems like a now now you're
starting version on the conflation of
good ideas with very very bad ideas
finally he says lastly the spread of
disinformation especially on social
media must be addressed we must reign in
these platforms and get in the habit of
seeking out accurate information
corporate america and religious
communities should encourage respect for
democratic norms participation in
elections and efforts to counter
disinformation
so now he's talking again about how he
gets to define what is disinformation
and what is not and he gets to control
that so we went very quickly from things
we can all agree on to things that very
few of us can agree on because we don't
trust you to actually handle those
systems but that's the entire goal
like okay so joy behar
i'm not going to her as some sort of
of apex of democratic intellectualism
because that would be disingenuous and
she is not but she is the it of the
democratic party when joy behar says
something this is what lies at the gut
level of the democratic party
what she says here is pretty much the
whole ball of wax the reason that this
has to be done right now the reason
january 6th is important the reason they
have to federalize election law the
reason that they have to go back to the
voting rights act even though the
supreme court basically says this
doesn't apply 50 years on
the reason that's to do this is because
republicans might win
that's why that's why the urgency that's
why the the outsized screaming that's
why the crocodile tears here's joy behar
of the view
you know i remember in watergate it took
a it took a long time before they
actually nailed all these people it
doesn't happen that fast the wheels of
justice grind slowly i i'm not losing
hope yet but i will worry in november if
the uh republicans take over the house
and the senate that will be the end of
the beginning of the end for this
country
oh if they win the house in the senate
it's the beginning of the end of the
country well that justifies pretty much
anything does it
i thought from jimmy carter we're
supposed to end polarization
nothing ends polarization quite like
saying that if your political opponents
win an election it's the end of the
country
but that's that's what's um they are
simultaneously making the case the
political polarization has to end and
the only way for political polarization
to end is for them to win from now until
the end of time that is one way to end
polarization is to is to create a
monopoly monopolies and polarization
because now you don't have two poles i
only have one
but that is not the way that you
effectuate actual peace harmony and
civility in the united states i said
this when joe biden took office he came
in he said i'm gonna be a unifier not a
divider and i said okay unity is great
but by unity do you mean tolerance for
other people's point of views pursuit of
moderate policies approved by a majority
of americans or do you mean i'm gonna
cram down whatever the hell i want you
shut the hell up
because that's two separate ways of
creating unity
it is fairly obvious that he meant the
latter we'll get to more on this in just
one second first let's talk about
getting in shape
so sometimes it's hard to schlep out to
the gym right or you want to work out
and it turns out that your local gym is
already closed it's too late at night or
it's too early in the morning or
something well i'll tell you what i've
been doing i've been hopping on my
echelon bike echelon brings the gym home
to you
when you're trying to reach your fitness
goals it can really help to have
world-class instructors choreographing
classes music from your favorite artists
and a community of hundreds of thousands
of people who can give you that extra
push echelon gives you that echelon is
the affordable way to get the workout
equipment the workout community and an
instructor's motivation right in the
comfort of your own home echelon's
fitness app provides you thousands of
live and on-man classes with great music
with echelon you can work out anytime
day or night and crush your fitness
goals just pick your class climb the
leaderboard cheer each other on give it
your all echelons certified fitness
instructors are supportive engaging and
fun they really know how to get you
moving i know because i use echelon
pretty frequently they've got around the
clock classes for the family they've got
full body workout programs that keep you
coming back one membership covers a
family of five right now for a limited
time podcast listeners get up to eight
hundred bucks off msrp which is a
fantastic deal to get this exclusive
podcast discount text ben to 81 81 81
again text men to 81 81 81 get up to 800
bucks off msrp text ben to 81 8181
message and data rates may apply see
terms for details alright we'll get some
more on all of this in just one second
first tomorrow is a huge day for the
daily wire and frankly for the country
because we have a lawsuit against the
biden administration's tyrannical vax
mandate and tomorrow is the day the
supreme court is going to convene to
hear arguments on the legality and
constitutionality of joe biden's descent
into medical tyranny so we are trying to
push for our do not comply petition to
have as many signatures as humanly
possible we're well over a million at
this point we would love to boost that
in advance of the hearing tomorrow head
on over to dailywire.com do not comply
right now we are counting on you to help
us put a stop to this disgusting
tyrannical federal overreach you're
listening to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
alrighty so again the agenda here is is
very clear january 6th the center of the
universe because the left wants to do
things so for example there's a piece in
the new york times today from cynthia
miller idris director of the
polarization and extremism research and
innovation lab at american university
the first part of this column america's
most urgent threat now comes from within
our most urgent threat now comes from
within okay and what is that threat that
threat of course is the january 6th
riot types
so what is her recommendation as to
policy
quote because extremist ideas are no
longer limited to an isolated lone wolf
fringe the united states should focus
less on isolating and containing a few
bad cells and more on reducing the
fertile ground in which anti-democratic
and violent extremist ideologies thrive
it needs a public health approach to
preventing violence extremism this is
where all the bells should be clanging
right because whenever the left says
public health approach think about what
they did over public health over the
last year and a half over the last few
years public health meant they could
lock you in your home and send your
children home from school interminably
you could force masks on your face and
force vaccines into your arm and when
the left says public health approach
they mean we can force you to do
anything we want that's what they mean
says this columnist this means that
federal state and local governments
should invest in and promote digital and
media literacy programs civic education
and other efforts to strengthen
democratic norms and values american
leaders should lead by example in
rejecting disinformation propaganda
online manipulation and conspiracy
theories it's not an easy fix and this
shift in mindset will not happen
overnight but inclusive equitable
democracies make it harder for extremist
ideas to take root and spread
no one wants the federal government to
police people's beliefs
but
but and always remember the first rule
of but everything that comes before the
but don't matter but the u.s
government's focus on using conventional
counter-terrorism tools fails to account
for the generally unchecked spread of
disinformation and conspiracy theories
propaganda targeting racial and
religious minorities and the increasing
dehumanization of those with whom one
disagrees these are important precursors
to violence what would january 6 have
looked like if policy makers had focused
on these precursors
many of the americans who stormed the
capital last year were immersed in a
universe of disinformation that
convinced them they were heroes acting
to save democracy a public health
approach to preventing violent extremism
would shift prevention work away from
security and intelligence experts away
from wiretaps and cultivated informants
and toward social workers school
counselors and teachers mental health
experts and religious leaders to focus
on social support and democratic
resilience
in such a world in such a world the
rioters lives would look very different
they would have been taught in school or
through programs in sports clubs or
faith communities to recognize
disinformation they would have been less
susceptible to claims about a stolen
election if you were to flirt with those
claims and mention them to a family
member or a friend the relative or
friend would know how to get help there
would be dedicated resources like a
toll-free support line or gatherings
akin to alcoholics anonymous meetings
that could offer counseling and
intervention
no approach can totally prevent
radicalization but a more holistic one
is better suited to defend against
mainstream extremism
so the the idea here is that um we need
the federal government to get involved
in how people consume information oh
won't nothing go wrong there just leave
the feds involved and how people consume
information and sponsoring programs with
regard to how people consume information
that that would be good that'll probably
work out well no danger there
everything's fine okay so here is the
thing the the notion from the left is
that january 6 represented an
institutional threat to democracy
the truth is the true powers in our
society are all on the other side
every major power in the united states
is not only on the other side of january
6th they're on the other side of the
aisle from the conservatives generally
there's a like the great myth of january
6th is that democrats and and their
allies
are a
put upon group of people who have no
power in the american political
discourse and therefore they must use
the power of government in order to cram
down their point of view and restructure
elections the reality is that every
major institution in the united states
has been performing
a soft takeover of all of our political
thought and the way politics is done in
the united states
thomas edsel has a piece in the new york
times that's just astonishing okay this
piece is about what happened in 2020
which for the record is much more in
american tipping point than what
happened in 2021 what happened in 2020
with the black lives matter riots in
which every major institution in
american public life immediately
swiveled into line and began pouring
billions of dollars into a radical cause
should be far more far more of a cause
for concern
than 200 300 500 droogs running into the
capitol building breaking some windows
and getting arrested
because here's the thing
in order for there to be a coup or an
insurrection typically you have to
number one have a plan which they didn't
on january 6. and number two you
actually have to have some sort of
institutional backing which again they
did not on january 6th but the radicals
on the left do have institutional
backing
there's no one who's too radical for the
left and there's no program too radical
for the left and the institutions that
back it thomas edsel has a piece
yesterday about the institutional
support for the black lives matter
movement in 2020 ready for this the
killing of george floyd and the
nationwide black lives matter protest
that followed drove an exceptionally
large increase in foundation grants and
pledges to criminal and racial justice
reform groups and other causes
candid is a website that connects people
who want to change the world with the
resources they need to do it publish
what does candid's grants data say about
funding for racial equity in the united
states by a person named anna kube july
24 2020.
kubrow in the month since george floyd's
murder by minneapolis police who
witnessed a surge in attention to
long-standing anti-black racism in the
united states although racial inequality
is hardly a new phenomenon the public
reaction to these events does feel
bigger and more broad-based before
floyd's death candid found that
philanthropies provided 3.3 billion
dollars in racial equity funding in the
nine years from 2011 to 2019.
so something in excess of 300 million
dollars a year
major corporations and philanthropies
from 2011 to 2019.
since then candid calculations revealed
these totals for 2020 and 2021 12.7
billion dollars in 2020 11.6 billion
dollars in 2021
for quote unquote racial equity funding
okay that that that is a grand total
if i'm doing my math correctly of 24.3
billion dollars 24.3 billion dollars in
2020 2021 coming from major institutions
in our society for the black lives
matter movement
yeah i know the conservative movement
really well there is no way in hell the
conservatives have ever spent anything
remotely like that in a two-year period
on anything political including
elections
okay on a presidential election
conservatives might spend i don't know
what a billion dollars maybe
okay but
on all other 24
billion
in two years on black lives matter
this included mackenzie scott 2.9
billion the ford foundation 3 billion jp
morgan chase 2.1 billion kellogg 1.2
billion bill and melinda gates 1.1
billion silicon valley community
foundation a billion walton family
foundation 689 million the william flora
hewlett foundation 438 million
foundation to promote an open society of
this george soros 350.5 million dollars
the institutions in our society do run
in one direction the institutional power
in our society runs in one direction
to
to suggest that the institutional power
and the threat to our country lies in
the direction of a few hundred people
who went
as far as i'm aware unarmed into the
capitol building there's no guns found
on anybody in the capitol building so
far as i'm aware that that is the true
threat to democracy and the true threat
to democracy is not the fact that all of
our institutions from politics to media
to corporate life have swiveled behind a
radical agenda that undermines
political comedy in the country
is a is a wild misdirect which of course
is what this really is right it is all a
wildness direct all righty we'll be back
here later today with an additional hour
of content in the meantime go check out
the michael moles show in today's show
trump cancels his january 6th rally you
can hear more details about that story
over on michael's show that's available
right now i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover and our production manager
is pavo weidowski associate producer
bradford carrington editing is by adam's
science audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant jessica crand the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022
today january 6th we commemorate a
wonderful and glorious event
the pope tells millennials to stop
treating their puppies like children and
elon musk complains that there are just
not enough people check it out on the
michael knowles show